ich glaube dass die gegenwärtige
Regierung
riskiert die Bevölkerung zu überfordern
mit ihrer Politik und das betrifft nicht
nur einen Bereich sondern es betrifft
mehrere das betrifft die immer noch
nicht ausgestandene corona-krise die
politisch hätte schon längst beendet
werden können wie in den meisten anderen
europäischen Ländern auch aber es
betrifft natürlich jetzt die Ukraine
Krise die in eine Energiekrise wir haben
darüber gesprochen überführt wurde und
wird und ich befürchte einfach das ist
hier Gegenreaktionen geben wird seit der
Bevölkerung wir sehen es schon jetzt in
den Wahlen
bisschen auch dazu dass die Menschen
glauben sie können diese Sorgen nicht
immer mehr äußern das haben wir in der
corona-krise auch erlebt und das ist
auch jetzt hier wenn man ist einfach zu
schnell dabei Kritiker und andere
Stimmen abzustempeln eine Ecke zu
schieben und im Grunde zu machen und das
ist eine Art von Politik die irgendwie
letztlich auch von der Demokratie am
Ende wegführt und von der
Meinungsfreiheit und im Pluralismus den
wir haben und sie von Markus Söder
mundtot gemacht als sie eine integrat
verlassen mussten das ist ja nicht
gelungen aber ich hätte natürlich schon
lieber in auch diesen Ethikrat mit
meinen Ideen bereichert und ich glaube
es hätte auch dem Ethikrat genutzt
aber natürlich lasse ich mich jetzt
nicht mundtot machen was allerdings auch
nicht das ist für sie angefühlt ich habe
wirklich ich habe das damals auch
verfolgt habe gedacht eigentlich kann
das ja nicht sein dass jemand kritisch
ist oder kritisch den corona-maßnahmen
Gegenüber ist und dann gibt es ein
Politiker in dem Fall Markus Söder der
dann dafür sorgt dass das jetzt nicht
mehr so angebracht wird das
plattformuliert aber also ich so etwas
in der Art hatte ich auch zu dem
Zeitwort noch nicht erlebt auch noch
nicht wieder seitdem
also sozusagen diese unmittelbare dieser
Versuch der Politik einzugreifen in eine
eigentlich als unabhängig geltende
Expertise das ist etwas was ich auch
nach wie vor als ein absolutes No-Go
ansehe und
was dann auch glaube ich zurückschlägt
anschließend denn
wenn man wenn man wirklich hier versucht
in gerade in wissenschaftliche
Unabhängigkeit ja in irgendeiner Weise
in irgendeiner Weise also restringierend
einzugreifen sozusagen
dann wird das an anderer Stelle wird
anders zum Nachteil und ich glaube das
kann man durchaus auch sehen wo war wo
war der wo war der Knackpunkt also was
glauben Sie rückblickend hat das fast
dann zum Überlaufen gebracht das gesagt
wurde sind zu kritisch ja es sind ja es
sind zwei Dinge dass das eine ist ich
habe deutlich Kritik in den
corona-maßnahmen geäußert ich habe den
Lockdown deutlich kritisiert bereits
Ende 2020 dann Anfang 21 noch mal auch
dann dass er immer weiter verschärft
wurde ich habe auch andere Maßnahmen
kritisiert und dann habe ich aber auch
diese Kritik öffentlich gemacht und ich
glaube dass das manche der Meinung sind
man muss sich in man darf zwar die
Kritik äußern aber nur hinter
verschlossenen Türen und ich glaube das
ist ein Fehler also gerade auch wenn es
um Ethik geht muss man diese Debatte in
die Öffentlichkeit tragen und und das
habe ich vorher gemacht das habe ich
auch hinterher wieder gemacht denn das
ist für mich kein Verständnis von Ethik
Ethik lebt von der Debatte auch wie mein
klassisch bei den Griechen und dem
Sokrates der auf den Marktplatz ging und
mit den Leuten diskutiert dann so
einfach kann es sein natürlich ist es
heute ein bisschen komplex aber man muss
die Themen nach in die Öffentlichkeit
tragen und nicht hinter verschlossenen
Türen diskutieren und das weiß ich auch
heute ganz aktuell das werfe ich auch
anderen vor ich ich glaube auch dass wir
das Thema Ethik was ja eigentlich von
Ethik reden auch auf der bundesdeutschen
Ebene betrieben werden sollte dass das
nicht ausreichend und auch nicht in der
Ausgewogenheit betrieben dort bis heute
eigentlich also ich muss es müssen dort
stärker kritisch Stimmen gesehen werden
und zwar nicht nur hinter den
verschlossenen Türen und es ich beklage
eine schon also seit letztem Jahr
mindestens eine fehlende Ausgewogenheit
dort ein ganz aktueller Fall ist ja das
Buch von Brecht und Wälzer das wird ja
hart vor allem von Journalist ich komme
gleich noch darauf was Herr Kistler zu
dem Beruf sagen wird ich bin gespannt
aber ist das für sie auch eine Form eine
Diffamierung der öffentlichen Meinung
ja also das ist ja interessant weil ich
in vielem Brecht und Welter eigentlich
nicht zustimme in im Film sind wir
völlig unterschiedliche Ansicht aber in
diesem Punkt dass sie sagen es findet
eine Verengung der öffentlichen Meinung
statt es es findet eine Verengung in den
in den klassischen Medien statt ich
glaube genau das haben wir beobachtet in
den letzten zwei Jahren sind da würde
ich voll bei ihm sein und und ich ich
sehe auch diese Mechanismen die da
stattfinden in interessanterweise sind
ja Brecht und Welter die äußern sich
nicht auf den sozialen Medien
interessanterweise
das fehlt natürlich aber wir können ja
auch nicht sagen ja gut wir haben jetzt
als die sozialen Medien als Gegenstände
gegen die klassischen sondern es muss
auch in den klassischen Medien müssen
diese Stimmen erkennbar sein muss es
möglich sein auch abweichende Meinung zu
äußern ohne dass man gleich diffamiert
wird
Alexander Kessler wie sehen Sie das denn
mit dem Blick auch auf das Buch von
Brecht und Wälzer es hat ja die
journalismusbranche schon zum Beben
mit dem typischen das ist alles falsch
reagiert so hatte ich das Gefühl falsch
ist natürlich der Satz über mich drin
steht ich werde heute also auch ein
schlechtes Licht gestellt dann muss ich
natürlich in aller Form zurückweisen ich
mache durch alles vorbildlich irony of
das Buch hat natürlich die Schwierigkeit
dass die beiden natürlich alle Protein
haben die sie Meinung haben kann sie
sitzen in großen Show sie haben eigene
Formate also den beiden wurde und wird
nichts verboten zumindest die letzten
fünf oder zehn Jahren die bestimmen
sogar viele Debatten muss man ganz klar
sagen dennoch machen sie natürlich einen
Punkt dass wir vor allem am Beginn der
coronakrise teilweise vielleicht obwohl
ich da jetzt nicht so scharf sehe am
Beginn auch der Debatte und Ukraine
Krieg doch den Eindruck hatten die
Medienöffentlichkeit wollte das Mädchen
Publikum in eine bestimmte Richtung
drängen also nach dem Motto man kann
zwar schon anderer Meinung sein aber
dann gehört man halt nicht dazu also du
kannst schon sagen irgendwie Corona ist
vielleicht nicht so schlimm oder lässt
sich nicht impfen Klammer auf aber dann
willst Du halt vielleicht auch das Opa
stirbt Klammer zu das heißt man wurde
gewissermaß mit einer Meinung die
zunächst mal legitim ist in den Rand des
menschenfeindlichen gerückt und das war
glaube ich sehr sehr schlimm sehr sehr
falsch es ist danach auch besser
geworden und vor allen Dingen darf man
auch nie vergessen was für eine
Signalfunktion es hat für kleine
Debatten wenn man in großen Debatten
eine Meinung überrepräsentiert sieht
dann gewinnt vielleicht auch jemand der
zu Hause zuschaut weniger zutrauen sich
zu seiner eigenen abweichenden Meinung
zu bekennen aber wenn ich prächt und
Wälzer richtig verstanden habe hier muss
ich einmal kurz noch einhaken dann ist
es nicht so dass sie sagen es würde
keine Meinung gehört werden das ist ja
auch ganz richtig analysiert Brecht und
welche sitzen überall aber ich muss
sagen die Hämmer die über Herr Wälzer
beispielsweise ausgeschüttet wurde oder
überherr Precht zeigt ja schon ja man
darf dann seine Meinung sagen aber ist
ja auch immer das Gegenargument da muss
man mit dem dem Sturm dagegen halt leben
wenn es aber nicht die Medien sind da
würde ich gerne hätte als Philosophie
einmal fragen wenn es nicht die Medien
sind sagen wir mal die Verengung gibt es
nicht in den Medien woran liegt es denn
dann dass viele Bürger und da gibt's
Umfragen zu unter 50% trauen sich noch
ihre politische Meinung zu sagen laut
dem eins machen Institut woran liegt das
denn diese Schere im Kopf die man
anscheinend selber empfindet also meine
Vertrauensverlust der da stattgefunden
hat offensichtlich also was gegenüber
dem Medien geht gegen auch über gegen
der Politik natürlich ja also es hat
natürlich Erosionen von Vertrauen auch
schon vor der corona-krise geben aber
nie so dramatisch
ich glaube Menschen haben einfach
erfahren auf die Dauer hier kann etwas
nicht stimmen hier wurde uns immer
gesagt wenn wir diesen Lockdown jetzt
beenden dann wird alles ganz furchtbar
die Zahlen steigen es wird alles ganz
furchtbar und irgendwann das glaubt man
auch eine Weile eine Weile glaubt man
das aber irgendwann merkt man auch ach
Moments ganz so schlimm kann es nicht
mehr da kann es dann wohl doch nicht
gewesen sein das ist glaube ich eine
Meinung die sich auch in weiten Teilen
der Bevölkerung mittlerweile verbreitet
hat wenn man sieht wie wenig Leute
mittlerweile mit den Maske in diese
freiwilligen Supermarkt gehen das macht
man dann einfach nicht offenbar ist man
dann der Meinung obwohl Zahlen steigen
das ist vielleicht doch nicht ganz so
gefährlich ist also das meine ich
Erfahrung die man macht glaube ich
führen dazu und denn es ist glaube ich
nicht so sehr das Interesse für für
Herrn Brecht selber oder für Herrn
Welzer also gut die sehr werden
natürlich auch gelesen das ist richtig
aber es ist glaube ich etwas man liest
nicht dass man fühlt sich nicht abgeholt
man muss doch den den Leser das ist doch
eigentlich klassisch auch der abholen wo
er oder sie ist im Buch auch gern was
sagen ja aber bitte kurz halten weil wir
haben nicht gesendezeit ja das ist halt
nicht so die Strategie ich habe auf
einer Autofahrt durch Norddeutschland im
NDR ein langes Gespräch mit den beiden
gehört wo ihr Buch war auch gelesen nein
wo ihr Buch vorgestellt wurde und ich
kann nur zu einem Aspekt was sagen wie
die beiden Leitmedien herrschende
Meinung gegen Meinung nicht gehört auf
den ukraine-krieg angewandt haben das
habe ich als eine sehr naive
Relativierung des offensichtlichen
betrachtet und empfunden nicht das
Offensichtliche der verbrecherisch
Charakter die Menschenrechtsverletzungen
all diese Dinge da braucht man keine
Gegenmeinungen um die Tatsachen zu
Erkenntnis zu nehmen ich hoffe das
verzeihen Sie mir zu sagen ist es
manchmal ganz gut das Buch zu lesen war
ein Interview wird nicht immer ganz dem
gewahr das habe ich selber schon bei mir
erlebt aber damals